42.000 Autogrammkarten hat Ben chellan
geschrieben für ein sensationelles
Ereignis am 2 juni tritt er im Stadion
in Frankfurt auf Link unten in der
Videobeschreibung und er spricht im Talk
darüber dass er sehr verzweifelt war als
es am Anfang mit seiner Karriere ganze
Weile eigentlich nicht so richtig abging
das ist jetzt anders und er spricht über
noch viel mehr jetzt bis dann bleib
dran wie ist die Lage gut ja sehr gut
ich bin gut RF ja ist immer von auf muss
man gut drauf sein oder ja was heiß man
mus wenn man nicht gut drauf ist ja wenn
man nicht gut draf es gibt ja Momente wo
du gesundheitlich vielleicht halswehast
oder irgendwie oder irgendwie manchmal
bist du einfach mal müde vom
tourstressen so aber das das ändert sich
sofort wenn du die Leute dann draußen
hörst und die gehen ab und so und dann
gehe ich auf die Bühne und dann mache
ich ist bei mir wie Knopfdruck weil ich
sag die Zuschauer haben ja das verdient
dass du einfach gut drauf bist also ich
meine die haben lange teilweise sehr
sehr lange gewartet haben die titig
schon schon sehr früh gekauft viele und
dann warten die drauf auf diesen Tag und
dann freuen die sich und dann kommst du
depressiv raus das ja scheiße also du du
hast einfach ich habe dann aber auch
Spaß ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich bin
jemand der geht raus und hat Spaß ich
habe sogar schon mit Fieber Spaß gehabt
also vergisst es in dem Moment hinterher
geht dir dann voll beschissen und so
also wenn du krank bist ist halt da
merkst Du also wenn du krank bist egal
was dann merkst du auf einmal wie
anstrengend die Show ist also körperlich
ja also mir ja von Headbangen bis
Bauchtanz
hin und her laufen und so also das ist
da geht schon ab wie war das denn als Du
angefangen hast und noch ich sag mal
vielleicht vor 16 Leuten genist so
ungefähr 20 Leute aber wie war's da das
war ja da muss man ja ohne Kick machen
od war da war so dass die Leute gesagt
haben da waren 20 Leute gesessen in
600er Saal ich meine das ich meine das
heute 6000er sa aber 600 Saal ist auch
groß das merkst du dann wenn nur 20
Leute da sind und die setzen dann noch
so versetzt zwei da hinten dre vier dann
sagst du kommt doch bitte vor und dann
weiß ich noch wie ich gesagt habe soll
ich jetzt hier Programm machen soll wir
zusammen DVD angucken und dann haben die
gesagt eine halbe Stunde kannst du
machen und dann gucken wir zusammen was
ja das war das war einfach ich weißt Du
gar jetzt essen Zeche Karl 20 Leute das
war eine Stimmung du kannst halt mit 20
Leuten kannst du eine schöne Stimmung
machen so so gemütlich so
Wohnzimmeratmosphäre aber das ist schon
nicht einfach vor allem wenn der
Veranstalter den noch versucht
irgendwelche Hoffnung zu machen ja an
der Abendkasse kommen bestimmt noch 80
dann wen es 100 und dann gehst du gehst
du raus und sind Leute noch an der
Abendkasse gekommen ja Zi noch h 22 also
es ist nicht nicht einfach aber ich
meine desto mehr genieße ich das jetzt
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen also ich
genieße das ma mir das auch immer wieder
bewusst wie viel Leute heute kommen auch
in Norddeutschland jetzt hier in kfeld
heute 6000 das ist einfach Hammer und
jetzt am ich meine wissen ja genau
Frankfurt Frankfurt 40.000 und wir haben
über 35 000 Tickets schon weg also es
ist Wahnsinn du hast diese Idee mit
Frankfurt wann ist gekommen war Mario
Bart so das Vorbild hey das geht oder
hier in Köln sind ja auch mal hier
rüiger Rüdiger na wie heißt rüiger
Hoffmann Jürgen Becker zusammen
aufgetreten der Sporthalle vor da Dach
mal bitte wo treten die auf ja ja ich
weiß noch wo das erste Mal wo ich gehört
habe aze Schröder stritt in so ein
4000er Saal auf da hat jeder gesagt das
kann doch nicht funktionieren 4000er
Saal bei Comedy also mittermeer war
schon krass mit sein im Aug mittermerer
war war mit 2 bis 3000 Zuschauer schon
Wahnsinn Wahnsinn ja so und jetzt kommt
hatte dann noch kam dann irgendwie jetzt
ma da 4300 irgendwo ich weiß gar nicht
wo das war und es hat aber funktioniert
alles ja und dann kam Mario und hat das
ganz Ding gebrochen mit mit
Arenen 7000 Köln Arena weiß ich noch wie
das erste Mal Köln Arena und es hat
gerockt und und dann kam seine
Stadiontour und dann war es natürlich
schon so dass dass bei mir so das
Potenzial da war dass ich auch Massen
ziehen kann und die Zuschauer vor allem
meiner Region haben gesagt Bü mach doch
da auch mal stad mach doch du du bist
doch metler Rocker mach do mal so ein
Festival mach doch mit Vorgruppen also
nicht mit DJ Bobo ja Mario der aber
immer jedes Jahr hallenvoll macht ja ja
ist aber Hammer DJ Bobo e ich
bewundernwt bewundernwt aber be bei
meiner Richtung wollte ich natürlich
auch für die Z die so ein bisschen
Charts hören so haben wir natürlich auch
so ein Chartbreaker wie wie
glaspellenpiel aber wir haben natürlich
hauptsäich auch Metal Bands also wie
Gotthart von der Schweiz oder edgy die
dann Vorgruppen sind im Stadion also wir
werden richtiges Festival machen und das
ist geil okay ist das denn vielleicht
sogar einfacher umso mehr Publikum da
ist nur nach dem Motto einer wird schon
lachen oder eben bei 42 000 auch 1000
werden schon lachen es ist schon
einfacher das ja es ist sag mal
einfacher äh von einäh einer großen
Menge zu spielen ja äh als jetzt wenn da
nur ein paar Zuschauer da sind das ist
ja ganz klar weil die Leute ja so wenn
schon so viele kommen dann kennen die
dich ja auch oft ne das heißt die freuen
sich auch schon drauf also früher war es
ja so da sind die Leute haben dann nicht
mal geklatscht wenn du auf die Bühne
gekommenegangen bist ne so nach der
Mutter ah ja da ist so mach lass mal
kommen ne aber heute ist es so dass du
die Musik die Leute hören nur die Musik
es fängt jetzt gleich an und dann gehen
die schon ab teilweise und das ist
natürlich geil und dann kommst du raus
und Feiern dich erstmal das ist
natürlich wunderschön das ist aber auch
nach 14 Jahren akcker ist es natürlich
genießt man das auch und das ist so wie
die man hat was geerntet und jetzt zäht
man das ist wunderschön nach wie viel
Jahren war kam der so der Durchbruch
m nach ca 10 Jahren nach 10 Jahren oh da
habe ich daneben gelegen ich habe sieben
getippt weil das eigentlich so die
Karenzzeit ist es dauert eigentlich fast
immer nach die meisten sind na länger
gebraucht als die anderen ja weil ich
aus Mannheim bin
vielleicht der Dialekt noch ja ich weiß
nicht es hat einfach länger gedauert
aber also sag wir mal so regional war es
schon lief schon ganz gut also lief es
auch schon nach dem Essen paar Jahren ja
dann regional
ging schon in die größeren also regional
aber so bundesweit so und dann noch
Österreich Schweiz und so das muss man
erst sagen nach über 10 Jahr da als das
erste Mal die saapin aufgezeichnet wurde
in Mannheim mit C 10 000 wo wir dann
gerade so voll gekriegt haben das war
Wahnsinn wo auch keiner gedacht hat dass
ich das Ding voll Kriege und D haben wir
es voll gekriegt und dann wurd ja
aufgezeichnet damals von Brainpool und
ist dann auf RTL irgendwann gesendet
worden und dann wurde natürlich wurd
Deutschland irgendwie aufmerksam weil
die haben gesagt hey ist einer im aus
Manheim im Süden den kenne ich no gar
warum kriegt er so viel Leute we da muss
ja irgendwas gut dran sein so und dann
bleiben sind die Leute dann war das noch
einchaltquote war das auf Platz 1 das
war die hatte beste einschalt GEW an dem
Tag das war natürlich noch geiler das
sind mir am nächsten Morgen weiß noch
ganz genau da habe ich geguckt a RTL 890
Videotext und sehe ach Gott Platz 1
einchagquote Hammer haben viele geguckt
so und dann kam mir echt die Tränen weil
weil da habe ich gewusst jetzt ist es
glaube ich endlich soweit du hast so
viel Jahre dran immer geackert und jetzt
hast Du glaube ich so den ersten
durchsbruch geschafft so und das merkt
merkt man ja dann gleich beim Ticket vor
verkauft das M merkst du sofort wenn es
eingeschlagen hat irgendwie so richtig
dann siehst du auf einmal
hey im Norden oder in
Nordrhein-Westfalen es geht über die 4
500er zuschauergrenze hinaus und das war
schon Wahnsinn nach so viel Jahren die
trinen kommen ein ist das so ein
bisschen das Gefühl boah ich habe schon
fast nicht mehr dran geglaubt oder weil
es so eine wahnsinnig Strecke ist ja
oder was ist das es ist schon so dass du
natürlich ist psychisch auch eine
Belastung das ist ganz klar für jeden
Künstler du weißt Du in Dir also die
Leute die dann immer bei dir waren die
sagen
das rockt immer so du musst ins
Fernsehen mehr das ist das ist doch
Wahnsinn das ist doch super es hat auch
immer wenn wenn sag wir mal so und so
viel Zuschauer mal dann da waren dann
hast du auch immer gerockt es war immer
wo du gedacht hast das musst du doch
schaffen ab bestimmten Zeit bestimmten
Zahl meine ich ja ab ein gewissen Zahl
ich meine wenn du jetzt in 300 Saal oder
so so 80 90 100 Zuschauer gehabt hast
mal oder ein bisschen mehr sogar oder
mal voll dann hat es gekocht dann hat es
richtig gerockt und
und dann habe ich natürlich mit ganz
einfachen Mitteln kein Feuer nichts war
eine Kleinkunstbühne und so weiter aber
es hat gerockt und der Salah hat gebebt
und so und dann hat jeder natürlich
hinterher gesagt mench das gibt's do
nicht du musst do ins Fernsehen musst
doch mehr dass die Leute müssen noch ja
ja aber das war auch so ein bisschen wie
soll ich sagen in den Medien hat man oft
so Schubladen und dann so nach der motok
hier war ich schon der der quotentürke
sozusagen der war das war der Türke aus
Deutschland ja den man kannte und
das war sowies so ein Monopol 10 Jahre
lang kann man fast sagen also wir haben
ja ich habe sogar eigentlich ein
bisschen früher angefangen live als er
aber er ist schneller ins Fernsehen und
dann waren waren wir eigentlich fast
gleichzeitig sozusagen auf dem Markt
aber keiner kannte mich aber alle
kannten ihn also das war schon nichts
gegen ach Gott um Gottes Willen ne der
das das habe ich ih immer gegönnt aber
es war halt immer nur schwierig für mich
jetzt als Zweiter in Anführung einen
türkischen Namen nach vorne zu brechen
das war das war einfach schwierig ja
weil die weil die Medien gesagt haben ja
wir haben natürlich ist es auch sowas
und dabei habe ich was eigentlich ganz
anderes gemacht eigentlich ja au
natürlich habe ich auch deutschtürkische
schene da und dort mal wo sich
vielleicht auch so vom von dem ein oder
anderen Thema mal ähnelt oder so aber im
Grunde genommen war es schon was was
ganz anderes du musst es halt irgendwo
dich finden we wie kannst du eine
Schublade öffnen die neu ist die
irgendwie total individuell und da der
mannhimer Dialekt reicht anscheinend
nicht ja die Typen die ich mache obwohl
die ganz andere Typen sind reichen
anscheinend auch nicht so und D habe ich
irgendwann mal die Idee gehabt ich bin
ja Rocker ich bin ja eigentlich immer
die Rockmusik war ja schon immer me drin
da gehst du einfach mal mit so einer
ramsteinmusik oder irgend so einer
Metalmusik gehst du auf die Bühne
headbangs erstmal paar Sekunden und dann
machst du deine Standup so als als als
das dann das war das war eigentlich
eigentlich habe ja das war nur dies er
Punkt ich bin raus das wariß noch bei
Stefan R erste erste Mal bin ich raus
Headbanger gemacht Bam Bam Bam auf
seinem Tisch habe ich Bauchtanz gemacht
sein Tisch gesprungen gesagt ist hammer
ich war jetzt war schon Dreier und da
und dort mal so in so Kabarett noch nie
so und und und ja dann dachte Stefan
noch zu mir du muss öfter kommen also
der der hatte schon da gesehen ne und
dann wie gesagt und brainpol dann jör
grabusch hat mich dann sozusag das Ding
aufgezeichnet irgendwann so ging das
dann halt da wurd man immer mehr
aufmerksamer auf auf was da passiert mit
mir und und
und dann hat man auch irgendwann mal der
hat auch irgendwann RTL gesagt hey
der Dialekt ist zwar ungewohnt haben wir
noch nie ausprobiert aber probieren wir
jetzt einfach mal ja die Leute sind das
nicht gewohnt bundesweit so so ein so
ein Dialekt zu hören häig kennt man man
kennt
berlinerisch bayerisch und so
Dialekt und so ja aber ja Kölsch aber
man diese man ein das ist sowas ganz hat
funktioniert das überhaupt bundesweit
und dann hat man es probiert und es hat
funktioniert Gott sei Dank aber bist du
wirklich zwischendurch dann nicht mal
verzweifelt gewesen ja natürlich ja ist
ja klar weil du guck mal du du du fühlst
in dir du fühlst es wirklich so du
könnst es dann nach oben schaffen so du
hast das Gefühl du könnst da oben hin
kommen so aber irgendwie kriegst du
lauter Hindernisse und irgendwie ah ja
und ja und ich bin halt sehr ehrgeizig
aber mein Gott der Liebe Gott hat mir
auch vielleicht ein bisschen geholfen
dass es dann endlich einer gesagt hat
komm zeich wir mal auf probieren wir
machen wir das gehört auch natürlich
dazu dass du ein bisschen auch Glück
hast im richtigen Moment dann auch
irgendwann auch wenn er nach 10 Jahren
erst kommt aber der richtige Moment
hoffentlich kommt er irgendwann das ist
ich gehen ja auch viele ich kenne auch
viele Leute die sind richtig gut und
Komiker aber natürlich
ich habe ich habe da D man so ein
bisschen so wie Gladiator gedacht ich
habe gesagt du musst die Leute gewinnen
du musst die Zuschauer gewinnen egal wie
so dass irgendwann die Sender sagen oder
auch die Produktions fürm
he da kommen wir jetzt nicht mehr dran
vorbei wir müssen das jetzt mal machen
so und das war halt so mein Ziel das war
meine Hoffnung und die Hoffnung sagt man
stimmt immer zuletzt also wenn man das
jetzt heute so erzählt dann sagen die
Leute h da kann man gar nicht verstehen
das kann gar nicht verstehen dass es so
schwer war aber es ist war nicht einfach
und man kann es letztlich nur selber
machen das sag ich Youtuber immer da
gibt's viele die sagen ich bin so
talentiert mach mich mal groß ja das
geht nicht ne man kann es nur selbst
machen ne ja und es vor allem der lange
Weg ist ist der entscheidende diese
diese ganzen Casting Shows ja das was
ich auch manchmal verurteile also weil
das ist auch verheizen t t t ein Jahr
bekannt nächstes Jahr kennt keiner mehr
die Person oder oder vielleicht auch no
wenn es Glück hat nach zwei Jahren geht
es gut oder so aber die meisten
Superstars in Anführungszeichen kennst
du da noch welche die v 6 Jahren vor 5
Jahren Thomas ja okay ja es gibt den ein
oder anderen der es geschafft hat oder
der der weiter ja aber die meisten davon
also ich mE ist ja jedes Jahr und es
gibt ja schon wie lange gibt's schon des
ist über 10 Jahre und und die meisten
kennst du eben nicht mehr aber Thomas
God hat ein Weg vorher und das war der
Gag das war vielleicht das das Ding halt
kein 16-Jähriger der plötzlich nach oben
gespült wird und der war schon gut der
war schon gut der hatte nur mal der hat
auch ja es das ist halt das Problem ab
wenn du so ganz junge hast 16 17 JR die
haben ja keinen Weg was haben die für
ein Weg die sind da gecastet worden und
dann die haben Talent die haben riesen
Talent aber zack wird es dann sozusagen
wie verheizt und dann aber wofür ist der
Weg wichtig der Weg ist wichtig um zu
lernen Lebenserfahrung und dann auch zu
genießen auf dem Boden zu bleiben das
ist glaube ich ganz wichtig also die
meisten die sehr schnell nach oben
schießen schießen auch schnell wieder
nach unten also das ist das Problem und
dann haben sie psychisch dann kommt
diese Psych Variante die das das
belastet dich weil du hast
du du bist von heute auf morgen ganz
berühmt und hast aber gar nicht dafür
geackert eigentlich nicht viel geackert
also weiß nicht wie das ist vor 20 sten
du hast mal eine Party gemacht ja aber
so richtig auf Jahre hin wenig Leute zu
haben und die zu erobern und dann auch
das Gefühl zu haben h jetzt hast du
jetzt mal 80 Leute gehabt in der Stadt
so dann haben die rumgeschwommen undterb
hat da vielleicht mal ein Fan auritt
Quatsch Comedy Club h mal gehabt und
dann gehst aber wieder hin auf einmal
ist es 150 170 Leute also so eine Steig
W minimal aber weißt ah da hat sich was
bewegt die Leute die lieben Dich weil
weil du das hast du dir arbeitet nicht
mit Fernsehen sondern also ohne
Fernsehen und ich habe es ja teilweise
da und dort auch schon in großen Hallen
geschafft also ohne jetzt großartig viel
Fernsehen zu haben und das das ist
natürlich gibt dir auch Bestätigung dass
Fernsehen allein also Fernsehen hilft
dir halt natürlich für für die
bundesweite Geschichte
ja das ist ganz klar muss man ganz sagen
also alles nicht nur fansind sondern
eben auch ihr hier ja also Internet ist
in letzten Jahren sehr also ich meine
wenn dust auf Facebook z.B auch ja ja
Fans hast du da 1 fast 1,2 Millionen das
ist Wahnsinn ja ist Wahnsinn aber der
Weg ist dazu da damit man dann wenn man
den Erfolg hat letztlich in sich zu
ruhen und das damit umzugehen zu können
ja das krasse ist damals habe ich noch
gedacht wenn in Hamburg Schmitz Tivoli
das weiß das passen 600 Zuschauer rein
al wenn da auf der reperbah das Ding mal
ausverkauft mach dann hast du es
geschafft und wenn man jetzt überlegt
dass wir wenn 600 das ist äh das ist so
Clubtour jetzt mittlerweile also
Vergleich äh dass also das ist so in der
in die Ausmaß gehen würde ja dass das
ist dass du der der zweite bist der
weltweiten Stadion jetzt fül das ist
schon also der Gedanke allein darf ich
mir gar kein gedan ma wel genau so viele
gibt's ja nicht auch es gibt wirklich
weltweit ich habe mal echt erkundigt
kann do nicht sein aber es ist wirklich
so also Mario klar klar Nummer eins mit
den Zuschauerzahlen auch und du ja und
jetzt für den Deutschtürken hey das ist
super
ähm du hast gerade gesagt auf auf dem
Boden zu bleiben bist du auf dem Boden
geblieben ja ich komme immer noch z.B
komme ja immer noch auch raus zu den
Fans ich ich glaube ich habe wie viel
Autos hast du wie viel Autos hast das G
gute gute Frage gute Frage ja ich habe
ja ein polnischen Techniker der der
klaut die alle
irg nee aber natürlich ich bin nicht so
ein Auto na auch wenn ich das türkische
bluten mir ich habe natürlich klar fahre
ich auch gerne mal ein gutes Auto und so
klar aber es ist jetzt nicht so dass ich
jetzt sag oh ich brauche jetzt sich
Autos also xavia ist da ganz anders
drauf xavia hat 70 80 Autos ja aber das
ist muss man auch sagen das ist nicht
weil weil angeben will sondern das ist
sein Hobby das ist wirklich sein Hobby
das ist so wie so ein Junge in dem
Moment ja ich ich meine ich liebe ihn
dafür dass er so noch ist also er er
kauft sich auch jetzt sag wir mal ein
Campingwagen oder so was also alles was
ihm so gefällt
wie so ein spielzeugag ich Brau C da
brauch ich noch so ein Traktor da brauch
ich noch das also so so ist er halt ja
weiß du wie viel Autos Mario Bart hat
ich weiß dass er einige eine einige hat
aber wie viel insgesamt weiß ich nicht
muss und deswegen die Frage bist auf dem
Boden geblieben Mario Bart hatte hat mir
jemand erzählt aus hier den studius in
Köln der hatte hat da eben eine Woche
lang aufgezeichnet oder noch länger der
kam morgens mit Ferrari abends getrunken
kam am nächsten Tag wieder mitm Ferrari
am Ende der Woche standen da F Ferraris
da fragt man sich ist der noch auf dem
Boden geblieben
ähm es kommt immer drauf an wie wie will
man das messen auf dem Boden bist du auf
dem Boden geblieben nur weil du jetzt
mehr Autos hast oder bist du jetzt auf
dem Boden geblieben weil du eigentlich
so noch normal reden kannst dass du
weißt dass es zu schätzen weißt dass du
das und das hast oder äh auch wenn du
mit den Fans noral redest äh
respektierst du sie schätzt du die Fans
wie gehst du damit um wie redest du wie
ist deine Einstellung zum Leben
ähm ist es dir peinischen Müll runter
zuubringen oder nicht ja es ist mir eben
nicht peinischen Müll runterzubringen
ich gehe immer noch einkaufen da und
dort es dauert zwar alles länger
mittlerweile aber aber
es ist es ist okay ja natürlich nimmst
du dann da und dort mal ein Freund oder
ein zwei Freunde mit damit weil ich kann
ja einfach nicht nein sagen wenn Fans
kommen Fotos Fotos und dann ist
natürlich manchmal ganz gut wenn du
einen hast der sagt komm wir müssen
weiter ja natürlich das ist eigentlich
gar nicht manchmal weil du ja du kannst
ich kann nicht einfach sagen nee mach
ich mache immer gerne Foto ich kann
wirklich nicht sagen das geht nicht nee
ich bin ja auch dankbar ich bin immer
dankbar den Fans ich mE ohne die Fans
wäre ich gar nichts also das muss man
auch mal dazu sagen ohne Zuschauer würde
ich jetzt nicht hier mit dir ein
Interview machen würde ich jetzt nicht
da und dort das und das Autofahren da
haben wir es Wiederau ja nee das muss
man einfach man muss auch dankbar aber
ich möchte auch wieder viel zurückgeben
ich meine ich kriege auch viel Feedback
und ich versuche natürlich seit es geht
mich um die Fans zu K kümmern ich kann
die Autogrammstunden nicht mehr auch bei
60009 oder kann ich natürlich nicht mehr
durchziehen wie früher
da waren die Hallen auch kleiner aber
jetzt wirst du 4 f Stunden manchmal
stehen und und und das ist halt einfach
eine riesen Belastung die wenn du willst
ja das morgen z.B bin ich in Lemgo da da
willst du ja dass die Leute genauso
deine Energie haben auf der Bühne wie
jetzt heute in grefeld und und dann sage
ich ey Leute bin ich böse aber eine
Stunde mache ich eine Stunde Autogramme
Problem ist das hat sich jetzt schon so
rumgesprochen dass er ist eine Stunde
macht dann gehen die Leute teilweise bei
der beim beim Finale oder kurz vor der
Zugabe gehen vieleum dann zuerst bei der
aut und dann sind die be am Anfang habe
ich das voll persönlich genommen was
denn los mit euch wir hab doch gelacht
da waren auch Leute von der ersten Reihe
die gelacht haben Spaß gehabt dann sagen
und so ne so muss du die bah kriegen ne
und dann oh nee gehen die alle jetzt
also das ist Derin Nachteil ja du willst
dass sie bis zum Ende bleiben ja aber
manche sagen halt J komm die Zugabe
verzichte ich jetzt lieber und
hauptsälich habe mal ein Foto mit ihm
autogramm also das ist halt so dein
Nachteil ja wahnsinn wie du es machst
ist es falsch aber kann es nicht allen
recht machen und sind so viele aber ich
gehe trotzdem immer wieder raus auch
wenn es auch wenn du dann natürlich
andere vielleicht nicht damit vertrösten
kannst irgendwie aber das Feedback ist
so wunderbar also es holt Dich auch ein
bisschen ist so ein bisschen wie ein
Absacker du hast die Riesen Show gehabt
du Wahnsinn mittlerweile kommen die
Leute am Ende vor dann denkst du es ist
wie ein Rockkonzert die das ist
teilweise stehen die dann alle und und
und dann am Ende W Zugabe dann hast du
ja den fankontakt direkten und dann
kriegst du auch manchmal so Geschichten
erzählt weißt du so wie eine Frau gesagt
hat e mein Kind ist behindert und so
weiter und sie machen es voll glücklich
durch durch ihre Comedy und so das sehe
ich mein Kind wieder lachen oder eine
Mutter ist gestorben von der Tochter und
und dann jetzt sagt sie seit seit einem
Jahr trauert sie aber durch mein DVDs
und durch meine Comedy lenkt sie sich ab
und und wenn du solche Geschichten HST
die kriegst du solche Geschichten
kriegst ist am Wahnsinn wenn du die
persön nicht hörst also nicht dass ich
danach giere um Gottes Willen ich hoffe
dass nie Leid irgendwo in der Familie
ist aber wenn du sowas hörst dann weißt
Du genau das motiviert dich auch
weiterzum machen du machst das richtige
du kannst natürlich nicht jeden recht
machen es gibt immer der eine oder
andere sagt na ja mein Humor ist ist
vielleicht jetzt nicht aber mein Gott es
den meisten die da sind gefällt es und
das ist schön jetzt hast Du
autogramstunden erwähnt du hast gibt
jeder Besucher in Frankfurt das ist
krank bekommt eine Autogrammkarte die
Hand signiert ist hast du die schon alle
unterschrieben wie geht das hast Du darf
ich mal deinen Arm sehen ist irgendwie
recht hast irgendwie sehündung oder also
zwischendurch dachte ich bekomme ich das
und dann ist es natürlich so du gehst
natürlich bei 42 000 habe ich erstmal
das war so eine Idee wo ich gesagt habe
na gut beim Stadion kannst du nicht
rausgehen ja da haben die schon auf mir
sind auf den Hut gestiegen also auf Kopf
gesagt hey bülen das geht bei uns im
Stadion nicht das gibt's bei uns nicht
Stadion Autogramm das Chaos kannst nicht
machen kannst du Sicherheitsleuten nicht
zumuten da will jeder dann rausrennen
und das eine Fernseh Aufzeichnung da
muss jeder bis zum Ende bleiben weil
Fernseh Aufzeichnung und und und wegen
Bilder und so weiter macht das nicht das
ist Chaos und so so sag ja wie mache ich
das denn ne jetzt machst du einmal
Stadion und gehst nicht raus okay dann
machen mal für jeden Autogramm
individuelle mit nummeriert nein ja W
und dann haben wir jetzt und dann habe
ich gemerkt auf wie krank die Idee ist
weil ich habe seit Dezember bin ich erst
im jetzt Anfang Mai bin ich fertig
geworden also ich bin das ist oder Ende
April jetzt das war Wahnsinn also das
ist weil du du denkst immer okay dann
machst halt mal zwei D Tage und dann am
Stück geht nicht weil nach ein zwei
Stunden bist du so oh nee ich kann nicht
mehr und dann dann schiebst du es auf
den nächsten Tag und nächsten Tag
deswegen zieht sich das dann auf Monate
aber ich habe es GT sei Dank geschafft
herzlichen Glückwunsch und herzlichen
Glückwunsch zu diesem wahnsinnsereignis
ich bin mal gespannt ja ich hoffe ihr
kommt alle wenn euch dieser Talk
gefallen hat dann wird euch sicher auch
der mit Summerjam dem Rapper gefallen
der der darüber spricht warum er gerne
den Beruf des Sohnes ausüben würde
dreimal dürft er raten und sensationell
ist natürlich auch der Talk mit dem
Comedian Serda somunjo der aus seiner
Zeit als Obdachloser gelernt hat dass er
das lieber ist als schlechte Rollen zu
spielen und überhaupt dieser Talk ist
ein Hammer Talk sparing quasi ein
kleiner Kampf zwischen ihm und mir also
unbedingt ansehen und ansonsten jetzt
könnt auswählen und bis dann Bib dran
ه